so we just sat down and this restaurant
is very very dark and auctions over
there he's being the obnoxious guy with
his life or cubism like no that's okay
but it's so funny how yes but not the
light to see the menu excited to eat
Houston waiting again I used to creating
a steak
now I'm gonna cheeseburger
so what did you just tell me on my man
up my only audience he walks through how
did that sound like so like this is how
you say hello
China mommy what is it me my how would
you say
thank you very much for this wonderful
meal that we've eaten today been
wonderful and appreciate everybody's
company and I hope everybody judge for
the same three and once we get home can
you say that drunken chocolate sauce on
my cake Hotel toga privileged
Davidge giorgia Christmas we're here
we're waiting for a table just call it
we've been waiting for like that power
but luckily we've just called us and
we're here at Jim
restaurants and bakery and Chinese food
because apparently Chinese food all we
have here that is open for us today
Merry Christmas
quietly
you know you send it in and get you
anything
mighty hoping though I can write three
there open don't know how do you know
that the ones that for you hit it so we
got these delicious shallow mouth which
is why wishes suit pork dumpling yes
it's a dumpling with soup in it and a
fork in la there was a release vault in
Saipan which is like world-famous now
start off in Taiwan right yeah we go
there all the time we love like Alice's
version of it this is like houses best
offering and what that food is how do
you eat it and exhibit saw some fighting
tools but I want to show you the anatomy
and assembly
I didn't order a water so I think that's
your enemy the dumpling is in a little
hole for all that soup now that's what
you got you got a pork broth you have
the pork meat in there and then the
dumpling Oh me two separately No
here is a soy sauce the vinegar with
some ginger shreds the best
Wow and what do we have here
got praise this is our Christmas lunch
extravaganza he's kind of Renzi ma a
bubble of the poop emoji I thought boy
the poops on you
well that's a little way more graphic
than I was intending that to be Wow
funny thing about Casey is that whatever
he's focused he personally lips I got a
loaded lips are so first look at that
he's resisting the purse I'm gonna try
it you ready okay ready for this not
good yeah you don't even finish your
since then you shut yourself up hey guys
look at my balls
oh you know that mole is my favorite
mole on your body really like when you
were born
you're a newborn baby I saw that mole
when I would kiss it every single you're
having like I thought it was so good it
made you look like a cute special little
boy
grandpa daddy bullying kids this year
Christmas won't keep so bad I feel so
bad and even by my plan of present I
feel really bad okay okay but I promised
him though once we get back home that's
when Santa will visit because I had no
time to get friendly every time we come
to Dallas we always come to this park
and the very first time that I ever came
in Dallas and I met Casey's family was
back in thanks kids lessons back in
Thanksgiving 2012 was the first time I
ever came here
and we came to this park and we we love
taking strolls it's so nice to bond with
his family and you know enjoy beautiful
scenery but since it's winter there's no
there isn't any it'll really I think
you're kidding me dizzy you're so lucky
you get to grow up here and arrow up
here I mean you put up a neighborhood I
grew oh yeah right the neighborhood that
you dig her up and was even more
beautiful than this I'm always so
jealous of his childhood he had such a
nice childhood I crumble by person she
did I always tell him he though he's a
white guy in an Asian guy's body oh yeah
this place is gorgeous and you're
blogging on blogging YouTube video
so are you you can hurt you okay mama
Chan and instagramming
oh no she blocked him oh man I almost
got it it's okay
don't believe anything Isaac you're
gonna try a nice white now I looked like
it hurt
what do you have right there but this
suit yes
you love it you just finished it oh how
much do you like it Isaac like 100
percent 100 percent what wouldn't you go
people one page I finish it what's it
taste like to you he doesn't know what
it is he likes it though it's that we
call it we told them it's porridge sweet
porridge but in reality though it's a
first bit yes spit from a bird we're
finally opening presents the Sun has set
it is gloomy blue out there 5:40 yeah we
should have been doing this in the
morning we woke up too late we're gonna
have the most casual Christmas present
opening very casual because Carrie and I
didn't even wrap like most of them
they're just gonna hand them out so all
the non wrap stuff happens to be yours
I'm assuming and all the wrap stuff is
all empty some of the gear is unwrapped
and putting these fake gift boxes classy
Christmas for classy people this is the
most Russian Roulette Christmas you'll
ever have Isaac you're my cute friend
you might not get a present
well my presence at Isaac was from the
whole family's mess with me later
oh I don't know what about
as far as what she's into us stuff so I
just got her some warm socks oh thank
you they better not worry
then here's this soldier like he's
called easy your colors right you know
yeah you do know her really well and she
does get cold very easily dude these are
perfect they're my favorite and the
colors if the coloring is on point
matches your lipstick right now matches
your pants and by default you do like
this call it right here yeah thank you
Casey your jackets what you didn't need
to give me anything
maybe gave me a grandpa jacket like this
oh wait till you see the check-in I got
you mommy hi I didn't get you anything
nice you told him yeah what a big huh oh
oh there you go nicely let's go get mr.
Chan a big hug - Merry Christmas mr.
Chan you get some love yeah that's all I
need I'm creating the Mysterio natira
Cemetery suck me Christmas
Oh weird kid yeah I can see your
underwear your present from you know
Carrie and
and watching and and oh okay why do you
always give me your back for Christmas
present opening oh they know you so well
- ha baby Oh careful
there's just LEGO pieces thank you so
much
well there is a real a very cool power
hovering brought the hug yeah yeah oh
here's your present
oh thanks man to see that Tommy tell you
that it was a jacket there
you already know cuz he kept texting you
over in Japan they have a full rating
eight one but they had a boom of
collaborators cool though but yeah at
the Pluto lab at the shark buddy thing
you want yeah thanks I told you about
this writing this is every boy's little
dream is to have a fake shark hoodie
there we go we made your dreams come
true they made a little boy for the
Christmas I got you a little boy does it
fit again so this is the very
sought-after bathing ape style hoodie
can you see anything at all no what is
this completely pointless I got the
socks I just noticed that huge box and
the color that I love
and it's really huge why Turner gonna
yes okay I guess I guess it is cameras
on you the box is in your hands already
what happened to that thing - Tiffany
from Casey
Sharon Ella yeah yeah you want to
thought I should try and keep up our
tradition of having Tiffany's for
critters II hope you still need this
even after you apply yourself as percent
of ten oh now I know what it is Bert I
love you and there's a token of my love
for you the woman of my dreams
Katie oh my baby thank you get excited
you didn't want to believe there was
Tiffany yeah I didn't want to believe it
but it really is oh my god it's just the
václav so your mama thing this is the
biggest Tiffany box I've ever opened in
my life oh yeah
this is nice this is so nice oh there's
another bag in here thank you so much I
loved you're welcome thank you this is
one thing that you guys find there oh
it's not like it though yeah my dad does
not do gifts at all receiving or giving
at least I don't like receiving gifts
but at least I give him out huh it's a
really happy with during the holidays
what do you think about this year's
Christmas did you like it
those mean I have to edit this video
like real fast to make it relevant